the stockholm major was the most
important major in cs go history looking
for the next and it's yet
smoke's gonna start oh what a recovery
he wanted to look away
between the online era and real
competition from another game cs go's
future was called into question for the
first time in years it sucks that cs is
quite literally dying but when
counter-strike needed it most the fans
turned up both in the arena and online
stockholm are you with us
[Music]
[Applause]
an absolute disaster
and the faithful were rewarded with more
than just an incredible spectacle cs go
fans witnessed history and the game may
never be the same that's going to be
only nico there's no time he just has to
want that clock kick down this is it
[Applause]
after a brutal year and a half of online
play the counter-strike community needed
a win the 2019 berlin major was huge
astralis cemented their era and young
teams proved their medal on the biggest
stage in cs but that was years ago in
fact the pandemic delayed the major so
much that when the stockholm major
started it had been an excruciating
795 days since berlin between almost two
years of online play the threat of
valorant poaching some of cs go's player
base and the death of pro cs in n a cs
had changed that's a big l to the
community to lose n a because i think
they brought so much hype and so much
excitement into the game and scene after
the reality of the pandemic set in teams
had to adapt to the online environment
and several new contenders stepped up
ready to compete with the game's best he
just has to hit this shot and he's done
it for heroic
the leader
calling well above his ears clearing
corners
you're an animal heroic have done it and
i just can't believe it teams like
heroic and gambit rose through hltv's
global rankings but a lot of people
didn't think their success was legit
because all their big wins happened
online but it's all theirs he just has
to not defuse three seconds two it's
done
gambit baby they've done it
so one of the reasons the stockholm
major was so important was that it was
gonna prove whether or not these online
teams were truly the future of cs go or
if we all spent the last two years
wasting our time watching online cs for
example heroic were one of the biggest
breakout teams of the online era but
their roster was almost torn apart by it
we as fpx
heroic
call us whatever name you want will not
be finishing the first group stage of
flashband
probably just won't be playing the
cinnamon though let's be real
heroic bounce back though with wins at
esl one cologne and esl pro league they
were cs go's hottest team in this online
era despite all the controversy
surrounding them but their results
leading up to stockholm weren't as solid
and they didn't exactly have a lot of
major experience either this is the
first time you have made it to a major
playoff stage can you tell me how you're
feeling right now
yeah i mean it took eight years to get
here uh so the the twitter as well i
played the very first counter-strike
major in 2013 like you talked with get
right about
and yeah it took me eight years to reach
playoffs and what a better place to do
it than stockholm it's amazing
nicod is in charge of that tesis with a
beautiful spray but it is not enough for
the double he very nearly had it and now
kadian on his own one versus two he gets
one tries to shoot through he picks up
an ak continues to spray he can't catch
jaby just a bullet away and canadian
he's still got a little bit of a chance
here jaby's on the other side and
there's the headshot there's the clutch
the quad kill takes a deep breath
refresh now knows that he's got one on
the left and he has to assume he's got
one on the right there's the head shot
oh sorry
double kill for a refresh he sees the
plank coming as well kicker is gonna
walk right into it
smoke's gonna start oh what a recovery
he wanted to look away and now tesis is
put into action and he's boosted up they
have no idea he can hold the trigger he
can just chill he's going to get both
kills for free and they think the bomb
site is clear tessus has them all full
and there it is heroic made it all the
way to the semi-finals proving almost
single-handedly that results in the
online era did matter but heroic weren't
the only team to beat the haters gambit
also had a lot to prove at cs go's most
important major like heroic they won
some important online tournaments and
also like heroic many chalked their
success up to an online fluke but at the
major
gambit showed up
so happy shiro gets one he's still up
close to the double oh
that is fantastic but surely it's a free
kill for kicker surely
well he's blasting the ball oh no i'll
be serious there is so much trouble here
exile coming in with a kill on leanness
and now they're both stuck shot in the
back of the head the fanny coming in and
that's absolutely everything they needed
a triple and gambit gonna be at six to
three in the end gambit fell to navi the
tournament favorites but no one could
blame them for that and gambit's top
four finish stands as unquestionable
proof that the team was legit the whole
time when you look at the top eight
teams in stockholm and consider other
teams like firia and virtus pro who each
took home some big events when lands
were impossible it seems clear that the
online era really did matter while the
success of online teams was definitely a
big part of why this major was so
important there was another storyline
that made it so huge
simple as ascension
navi looked like the best team in the
world right before the pandemic but lost
their footing in the game's early online
days
two members of navi now just one black
and yellow jersey it's all done
defending champions dethroned in the
group stages and it's the plucky swedes
the new look nip to take the win still
by the time the lands were on the
horizon they returned to dominance for
hp wants to check ct simple's not going
for it but the suitor versus simple and
it's good for the navi boys only zai wu
can possibly save them only zywho can
deny the intel grand slam navi a couple
of bullets is all it takes and there it
is
their domination is secured
but navi fans knew to curb their
enthusiasm even when things look good
na'vi made it to the grand finals at
three different cs go majors losing to
team envious luminosity gaming and
astralis they didn't win a map in any of
those series
flamie now with the 570s baiting the
pair of short b is red touching the bomb
are going to peak
holding it now and there is it it's just
out of flame it's not going to happen
astralis has won let's face it london
but everyone's attention wasn't on
navi's legacy it was on their star
player
simple
simple won everything a cs go player
could win short of a major he amassed
mvp awards won the grand slam and even
earned the graffiti the stockholm major
was simply put his best chance and he
played like he knew that he played like
he was born to win oh simple with the
off got the first one more close up oh
of course he has that as well and at a
third that is spectacular he's at the
major and he's not wasting any time fit
with the second shot connects and simple
in the meantime finds another head shot
oh and then another one
where does this guy do it shiro now the
last one alive here for gambit hoping to
be the hero oh my god that is disgusting
ah look at confusion on simple why is it
gotta be so easy gambit get to set the
pace and that's simple he's not waiting
around he's already taken shiro out of
the fight in the first round of this map
already simple as arseless he's going
for a third
and he's gonna get it
navi
on his way to the grand finals simple
played like a man possessed and then at
the end of the bracket nico and g2 were
waiting for him but instead of backing
down simple amped up the pressure and
fans were treated to a historic major
finals performance flash off simple nose
and simple's quicker
only one kid keep your eyes on perfecto
and simple plucks jacks from the pack
[Music]
the hard clear the five there and
straight through the corner three four
from simple
this is his world we're just living in
it looking good and it's simple and bit
finds it to perfection
and simple sitting no no
defend the shot an absolute disaster
that was it that was it again
there's no time he just has to watch
that clock kick down this is it
zombie
dropping a 30 bomb on ancient and
getting 40 kills as part of a huge
comeback on nuke symbol didn't just win
his major
he dominated it
it feels like i told myself that i will
stay in navi
and we measure with them i promised
myself
and we did it and
a lot of people didn't believe and make
some jokes but we did it and major is
ours major is navi
the online era made everyone doubt
results it made people not really want
to watch cs valorent was taking
attention away from cs go and if simple
somehow lost the one storyline everyone
cared about would have been cut short
but in the end it was the perfect major
and it was exactly what the cs go
community deserved
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk